we're witnessing a model citizen here  transformed into a brutal machine  welcome to the home of towers and Smythe  consulting TSE is a firm fueled by greed  duplicity and moral decay I'm gonna need  some scouts so how are you doing  firing you I'm not leaving this building  until I plead my case sure good luck  with that  [Music]  what the hell is going on say hello to  the ID seven miners stress hormone  levels rise causing inhibitions to drop  and basic instincts to rise to the  surface all traces of the virus should  be eliminated in approximately eight  hours what are we supposed to do for the  next eight hours try to remain calm  hey extreme measures right  this is our shot  [Music]  I'm offering 150 grand for chose head  I'm talking about murder here you should  be offering at least 450 you want to do  this the hard way  during this much  I just picked it up  the party oh yeah  you  you